thank you I'm gonna tell you a story
with a happy ending once upon a time a
lonely boy in South Carolina was sparked
by the wonder of movies where he was
captivated by everything from Cowboys to
comedians to to movie monsters and then
he saw his first musical flying down to
Rio which introduced him to two magical
people named Fred Astaire and Ginger
Rogers they took the boy into a fantasy
world of such delight that he changed
his mind about going into his family's
dress business and started taking
dancing lessons he was nine years old he
kept on dancing and when he graduated
high school the shy and awkward 16 year
old danced his way up north and into the
chorus of a Broadway hit Pal Joey and it
was there he met the star of that show
who was to become his mentor friend and
in time his collaborator on a series of
films that would revolutionize dancing
in the movies the star was Gene Kelly
the boy was Stanley Donnan who followed
Jean to Hollywood as his assistant first
and then as his co-director and the
first film he directed by himself
starred his boyhood role model Fred
Astaire Stanley Donen had made the big
time and for the next 30 years he
directed and often produced a string of
classic films
[Music]
[Music]
here's that happy ending uh promised an
Academy Award for Life Achievement to
Stan Lee Donna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Marty it's backwards I should be giving
this to you believe me and I want to
thank the Board of Governors for this
cute little fella which to me looks
Titanic tonight words seem inadequate in
musicals that's when we do a song so
heaven I'm in heaven and my heart beats
so that I can hardly speak
and I seem to find the happiness I seek
when we're out together dancing cheek to
cheek
I'm gonna I'm gonna let you in on the
secret of being a good director for the
script you get Larry Gelbart or Peter
stone or hiking cats of rhetoric rough I
like that if it's a musical for the
songs you get George and Ira Gershwin or
author freed and her brown or Leonard
Bernstein and Condon and green or Alan
Lerner and Fritz low like that then you
cast Cary Grant or Audrey Hepburn Fred
Astaire Gene Kelly Sophia Loren Richard
Burton Rex Allison Gregory Peck
Elizabeth Taylor Burt Reynolds Gene
Hackman or Frank Sinatra like that and
when filming starts you show up then you
stay the hell out of the way but you've
got to show up you've got to show up
otherwise you can't take the credit and
get one of these fellas thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]